un air de fête ce matin sur le rocher et
un anniversaire qui met en joie les
monégasques comme les employés du palais
princier
tous attendent l'évènement et certains
s'y prépare même depuis plusieurs mois
la population a clamé leur naissance
aujourd'hui le prince albert ii et la
princesse charlène fait les un an de
leur enfant au coeur du palais je vois
sandzak c'est ici de dos à la caméra et
gabriela qui est très en voix styles
sont très actifs très joueurs ils sont
absolument adorable il change tout le
temps
un jour on me dit oh comme il ressemble
à albert et le lendemain aux ils vous
ressemblent tellement savez ce sont
juste des bébés on verra plus tard
il faut pouvoir passer beaucoup de temps
avec eux ce que nous essayons de faire
c'est très difficile a bien entendu là
dans ma position avec les obligations
qui sont les miennes et les innombrables
sollicitations ça en vaut largement la
peine
pour fêter l'événement gâteau
d'anniversaire et chants traditionnels
avec les monégasques sur la place du
marché
au pied du rocher employés commerçants
artisans en toute simplicité
[Musique]
m
ils paraissent très à l'aise avec tout
le monde qui rencontre avec d autres
enfants mais aussi avec des adultes qui
ont déjà été dans des situations où il y
avait plusieurs personnes autour d'eux
se comprend vraiment de façon tout à
fait extraordinaire
pour la première fois nous avons été
autorisés à suivre au gré des saisons
mois après mois de l'intérieur du palais
les grands événements qui ponctuent une
année à monaco
un an au coeur du pouvoir
juge jusqu'à cette manifestation
différente entre
dans cette principauté avec son
protocole
sa part de rêve
c'est vraiment prévu pour les beats on
va dire pour les gens qui ont vraiment
de grosses possibilités de gros moyens
ces rendez vous de prestige
avec la jeune génération de la famille
princière
ce que j'aime c'est à toutes les saisons
il se passe quelque chose il n'y a pas
ce qu'on appelle une saison morte à
toutes les saisons des quelque chose
d'amusant
mais aussi ses traditions et parfois ses
mystères dans ce palais où le grandiose
côtoie le plus intime la paix qu'il soit
heureux et en bonne santé et aimer c'est
ce qui compte le plus pour moi pour
conformer
[Musique]
ce matin ébullition en principauté de
monaco top départ pour le week-end du
grand prix de formule 1 dès demain plus
de cent mille personnes dans ses rues
pour assister d'abord aux essais puis à
la célèbre course prévue dans quatre
jours environ trois kilomètres de
circuits serpentant au coeur du centre
ville
embouteillages travaux et une surprise
personne ne l'a encore remarqué le
prince albert ii en personne sans
cortège officiel avant le grand rush il
effectue un petit repérage du circuit à
ses côtés david coulthard est champion
écossais de formule 1
alors comment ça se passe avec vos
enfants peu d'hésitation fantasque il
bouge beaucoup de bois car c'est du
sport
pour le prince au moment du grand prix
toujours la même excitation incroyable
ce que font les pilotes ici du casino
jusqu'à ce virage ça doit être tellement
excitant
le prince connais ce circuit par coeur
ce grand prix a été créé par son arrière
grand père louis 2 en 1929 matin mon
premier souvenir c'était en 1965
je m'en souviens très bien c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai réalisé ce qu'était
une course
le bruit l'odeur c'était pour moi une
révélation
monsieur bieber mark webber l'ancien
coéquipier de david coulthard dans
formule il a gagné deux prix à monaco je
savais pas que j'étais ici
alors il conduit bien des gens n'ont pas
très en forme il est connu pour taper
les barrières s'exhaler à ce soir ça me
fait toujours plaisir de voir ce gars
c'est ça qui est incroyable à monaco
tous ces champions pâques en f1 les
joueurs de tennis des skieurs de se
glisser pour le prince
le calme avant la tempête
car pour monaco le grand prix des enjeux
colossaux
retransmis dans 70 pays environ un
milliard de téléspectateurs pour la
marque monaco une exposition unique mais
pas seulement l'état monégasque investi
30 millions d'euros et doit ont récupéré
trois fois plus c'est également un enjeu
pour toute l'économie locale
quatre jours cruciaux pour la
principauté
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps sur le rocher
effervescence au coeur du palais la
résidence des princes de monaco depuis
le xiiie siècle le haut lieu du pouvoir
[Musique]
derrière ces façades aussi on se prépare
à l'événement un vrai tour de force et
un défi pour le colonel solaire c'est le
chambellan et l'aide de camp du prince
tout ce qui se passe au palais et sous
sa responsabilité
ancien des forces spéciales ce militaire
français s'apprête à vivre le week-end
le plus chargé de l'année
on est parti
c'est un gros week-end c'est d'ores et
déjà une grosse semaine à sa fin que
week end c'est une grande grande semaine
et beaucoup beaucoup d'activités
beaucoup de choses en perspective choses
qui vont se passer au palais des choses
qui vont se passer bien sûr autour de ce
beau circuit de formule 1 et puis là on
va essayer de bien cadrer pour que les
choses soient claires pour tout le monde
et pour que tout ça soit anticipé que ça
roule ce matin ultime réunion avec
l'état major du palais bonjour mesdames
messieurs ça s'il est resté assis bien
donc on faire un dernier point pour le
pour le pôle pour le grand prix on va
faire le tour du du programme tout de
suite autour de la table plusieurs
responsables sûreté publique carabiniers
secours communication objectif
coordonner tous les services autour du
planning princier donc je serai en
charge pour rempailler le prince pour le
déjeuner traditionnel à l'automobile
club 14 heures ouverture du circuit il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui va
venir sont des milliers de personnes qui
vont venir
il ya un enjeu qui est qui est important
à la sécurité du prince y à
l'organisation proprement dit on peut
pas se permettre de montrer des choses
approximatives
cette année moment phare le couple
princier reçoit au palais pour le grand
prix 800 personnes conviées à un
cocktail d'exception on reçoit chez le
prince ont recherché la princesse ils
sont chez eux et pas question que quand
elle ne remarque tout doit être
impeccable tout doit tout à tout a
fonctionné tout doit être tourné comme
une horloge au sommet de la tour de
l'horloge tout près du bureau d'alberte
oui oui bonjour monsieur christine ce
prix l'assistante personnelle du prince
depuis quelques jours son téléphone ne
cesse de sonner la soirée organisée au
palais déclenché des convoitises
si jamais il y avait vraiment une
quelque chose d'exceptionnel au pire des
cas on se permettra de vous appeler
merci tout le monde essaie de rentrer
par une porte ou une fenêtre c'est pas
moi c'est le prince mais on essaie de
faire au mieux pour pour faciliter la
tâche au souverain parce qu' on essaie
d'être réactif et de pouvoir lui
présenter quelque chose de concret et de
facile on a déjà on est déjà à plus de
800 invités pour la réception
donc c'est je veux dire les murs sont
pas extensibles et arrive un moment où
on peut plus c'est pas possible
jongler avec l'agenda du prince madame
ce prix il en a l'habitude
elle planifie chaque année pour le chef
d'état 400 audiences des centaines de
rendez vous et de voyages officiels
mais cette semaine l'équation s'avère
compliqué une vingtaine de ministres
d'accord 7h15 le matin ok pour l'instant
une urgence entre deux rendez-vous
passage éclair du prince dans son bureau
madame ce prix il en profite
un petit peu dingo canning
du coup les prix et voir avec vous vos
suggestions une interrogation voilà ceci
est le nouveau planning discours public
actions caritatives au rendez vous
diplomatiques
inauguration à monaco pas un événement
où l'on ne sollicite la présence du
prince un gage de reconnaissance
officielle bien sûr ça ne tient pas
compte de vos audiences du matin ils se
trouvent et rien ne lui échappe
mais je crois qu'il ya un autre passage
sur un hôte yacht après le bras après le
ledeen d'accord puis samedi le salon ou
tard ça va au-delà dès 16h30 ça peut
faire je crois que la princesse vous
accompagne d'égards oui non bon voilà la
réception bien sûr au total une
quinzaine de rendez-vous par jour
jusque tard dans la nuit j'ai l'habitude
j'ai une certaine habitude il ya eu même
des années où c'était pire que cela
j'ai juge jusqu'à cette manifestation
différente entre 18h et les héros donc
c'est vous dire que l alsace est un peu
moins
heureusement enfin je fais en sorte
aussi que ce soit un peu moins parce que
ça commençait à être très très lourd
monseigneur merci à plus tard tout à
leur mobilisation du prince mais aussi
des monégasques
économie et commerces locaux tourne à
plein régime
hôtels et restaurants affichent complet
tandis que les locations d'appartements
et de yachts s'arrachent à prix d'or
[Musique]
nous
des palaces flottants en bord de piste
unique au monde
les plus beaux de la planète jusqu'à 100
m
de quoi séduire de riches clients car
durant le grand prix
beaucoup sont à louer les tarifs sa
folle jusqu'à 25000 euros par jour
alors ce matin les équipages s'activent
pour préparer les bateaux les clients
arrivent des quatre coins de la planète
pour vivre le grand prix version grand
luxe
l'un des plus spectaculaires le bar en
trunk 44 mètres de long trois terrasses
matériaux précieux grand standing
de quoi rêver à l'accueil
laurent scénario pour le compte du
propriétaire
cette spécialiste en événementiel loup
ce bateau clé en main et en orchestre
toute la logistique durant le grand prix
dis-lui dans cinq petites minutes ou
alors tu m'envoies lourd a ouvert en
train de l'organisatrice s'apprête à
recevoir une famille de riches
américains et à les installer dans ce
lieu hors norme
voilà alors là la twin et si un deuxième
salon où les gens peuvent se reposer
dans la journée le soir comme ils
veulent nous on aime baril si la master
ici évidemment c'est des parents qui
vont être dans la master cabine une
suite parentale grand luxe de 50 m² avec
celle de bain du marbre de l'acajou
confort optimal pour le grand prix
quelqu'un qui rassure un bateau veut
vivre l'événement complètement et c'est
vraiment prévu pour les beats on va dire
ou pour les gens qui ont vraiment de
grosses possibilités de gros moyens du
luxe certes mais ce qu'ils payent c'est
ça à cette distance
ils pourront presque toucher les bolides
on a quand même le circuit qui passe
juste devant et c'est vrai qu'ils ont
quand même une vue imprenable sur toute
la ligne droite ici
le virage de la piscine bienvenus
suivez-moi et justement dans le salon
principal
les clients viennent d'arriver des états
unis ils sont accueillis par le
personnel du bateau
[Musique]
ghosn je vais vous montrer les chambres
et vous n'aurez plus qu'à choisir
on va descendre d'abord cela il y a une
douzaine juste ici
on peut prendre celle là vous prenez ça
aussi ok très bien merci
c'est le père de la jeune femme
un riche homme d'affaires de boston qui
a loué son yacht cinq jours pour toute
sa famille
mon père adore les formule 1 c'était son
rêve devenir au grand prix de monaco
il est à la retraite cette année et pour
ses 60 ans on va fêter ça ici en famille
vous êtes content on est très excité oui
plus qu'excitée c'est même un rêve de
l'autre côté du rocher dans le quartier
de fontvieille un rendez vous au stade
louis ii un événement insolite où le
public est là en costume cravate
le colonel solaire le chambellan du
palais mais surtout le footballeur que
tous attendent c'est le prince albert ii
comme les autres il a revêtu un maillot
à son nom
albert grimaldi le souverain sur un
terrain de foot
une tradition lors du grand prix un
match caritatif pour aider les enfants
défavorisés dans le monde deux équipes
hors norme pour récolter de l'argent
d'un côté des personnalités monégasques
notamment d'ex champion de foot c'est
l'équipe de l'ot de la star team menée
par le prince albert qui est le
capitaine
de l'autre des pilotes de formule 1 y a
un physique et là vous avez alonso alors
alonso c'est le capitaine il ya philippe
et masaya dire vraiment vraiment du beau
montre le prince passionné de sport
n'hésitent pas à donner de sa personne
lajoux est jeune il a il a pas mal joué
au football
il a fait du box il est bien évidemment
et sur son sport et de ces sports
prédiction c'est plus drôle est parti il
ne lâche jamais rien
ne lâche rien et puis les capable quand
même de m'attraper
or là ils sont ils sont ils sont un peu
mené par les par les pilotes de f1 pas
normal ça il pousse le prince pouces et
le passe tout le temps oh la la oulala
oh lalala lalala
[Musique]
que c'est dangereux
[Applaudissements]
et ouais ben oui lâche rien
le souverain ne disputera pas la fin du
match il a une foule d'obligations
l'important était de l'initier vous et
de quelques fans pour un autographe
le prince a un petit mot pour chacun
parfois avec humour j'ai piqué la place
dans l'assistance toutes les
nationalités jolies photos merci
beaucoup je vous en prie et bonne
journée
si vous voulez mon signé plusieurs ça me
ferait plaisir
5 euros la photo adacore
[Applaudissements]
bon attendez ça suffit maintenant et ce
match nul je viens de berlin des mois de
monaco à génial merci beaucoup
complet chanter tous c'est pas possible
vous parler allemand ici est un petit
peu nous sommes débrouillés
vous avez pris du plaisir là oui sauf
que je suis pas tenu très bonne forme en
ce moment mais je veux me faire un petit
effort pour
soutenir les camarades et soutenir la
cause c'est sympa c'est dans une bonne
ambiance avec une belle atmosphère
équipe était difficile adverse là bas il
son bureau et voir s pas fini le match
même si les taux des obligations
là il faut que j'aille saluer les
personnes pour une autre association
mais après je reviens pour le court la
fin du match merci
au pied du palais dans la ville retentit
le crissement des pneus
ce sont les essais de formule 1 toute la
ville de monaco est verrouillé plongez
dans un vacarme assourdissant casque
antibruit de rigueur
même pour les chiens impossible
d'apercevoir le moindre bolide sans
avoir payé sa place
du coup certains fans rivalisent
d'ingéniosité pour garder un souvenir
on ne voit pas grand chose
mais surtout on entend pour voir autre
chose que des arbres il faut mettre la
main à la poche tribune terrasse yacht
mais pour payer moins cher certains ont
trouvé une combine surnom des versants
du rocher une centaine de fans avec vue
imprenable sur une partie du circuit
entre arbres et buissons
c'est ce qui coûte le moins cher 75
euros la journée
à ce prix là on cadenassent sa place
pour retrouver sa chaise le lendemain
parmi ces campeurs passionnés de formule
1 une star
[Musique]
billy 45 ans il vient spécialement
décosse pour le grand prix depuis 16 ans
il vient chaque année sur cet
emplacement
ici c'est son paradis c'est ici qu'il
faut être on a la meilleure vue un écran
de télé ces 500 euros là bas sur les
gradins alors qu'ici ce n'est que 75 à
votre avis c'est qu'ils gagnent ont
regardé cette vue ya aucun yacht qui
offre ça vous ne seriez pas mieux sur un
yacht
oui je préfère être ici qu à cause des
gens c'est l'ambiance qui fait la
réputation de la colline ici c'est moi
qui met l'ambiance sur les yachts doit
vraiment s'ennuyer ce que ce mécanicien
de glasgow adore interpellé les pilotes
sur le circuit ses têtes de turc
le quadruple champion du monde
l'allemand sebastien vettel sur la ligne
terai cinq minutes sans de ton trou et
montre tout ce que tu sais faire
t'es pas tout seul ici mon gars au même
moment sur un autre versant monégasque
beaucoup plus chic lady monica bacardi
une riche résidente monégasque
elle s'apprête à assister au grand prix
à bord d'un yacht pour lui ouvrir la
porte son fidèle majordome cesare
[Musique]
la journée s'annonce formidable c'est au
port de fontvieille que monica bacar dia
rendez vous un parcours semé d'embûches
qui n'entame pas la bonne humeur de
monica bacardi héritière de la célèbre
marque d'alcool figure de la jet set et
productrice de cinéma elle tente de
rejoindre le yacht sur lequel elle est
invitée
impossible par la route le circuit
l'interdît il faut faire tout le tour de
la mer pour arriver sur les bateaux
c'est très très bien sûr vous vous
rendez vous le verdit d'extorsion
coldplay mais c'est moins amusant cet
excité d'aller voir les voitures les
courses
j'adore ça dort
pour monica le spectacle commence dès
l'arrivée au port avec cette parade des
plus beaux yachts de 30 à 100 mètres de
long la milliardaire ne s'en lasse pas
le temps des choix voilà on va choisir
l'un d'eux trop avoir regardé où les
plus beaux jeux sur l'eau c'est la
course folle des navettes
assister au grand prix à bord d'un de
ses yachts est un privilège rare sur ses
palaces flottants les ultra privilégiés
attendent le début de la course
chacun à leur manière à bord du yacht
sur lequel est invité monica le
champagne coule déjà à flot monica est
ravi ses richissimes invités viennent
des quatre coins de la planète
ils ont fait du grand prix de monaco un
rendez-vous ultramontain pour eux le
grand prix c'est forcément à bord d'un
yacht proche du circuit
l'odeur le bruit
c'est de penser de l'ensemble des
télécoms soupe avec beaucoup d
ingrédients
ça vibre et c'est les grands prix oui
est votre favori je veux pas me faire
des ennemis au non français
cette année
[Applaudissements]
et c'est parti pour le grand show des
essais des bolides lancés à 300 km heure
elio tiennent leurs promesses
[Musique]
dc spectacle assuré
sur le quai nous retrouvons billy
[Musique]
or voix qui crient nettoie bien ce
bateau il est sale
le mécanicien écossais savoure avec sa
femme le spectacle du luxe monégasques
bien loin de son glasgow natale ça ça
ressemble plus à ce que nous avons chez
nous là où j'habite on n'a pas de yacht
mais beaucoup de ces trucs là qu'ils
prennent l'eau qui coule mais surtout
avec son mégaphone billy a un objectif
entrer en contact avec les pilotes les
stars du circuit
pour sa direction les paddocks derrière
ses grilles ultra sécurisé une enceinte
réservée aux pilotes et à leur staff
mais billy a un plan
il a repéré ce bar qui surplombe les
écuries de formule 1
[Musique]
de son perchoir l'écossé guette les
pilotes
[Musique]
billy vient d'en repérer un l'homme à la
casquette
le finlandais kimi räikkönen qui me fait
chi minh êtes sûr
[Musique]
mais malgré l'enthousiasmé bruyant de
billy aucune réaction du champion n'en
suis pas sûr il a dû avoir une enfance
malheureuse n'a pas dû recevoir de jouer
quand il était petit il ne doit pas
savoir sourire
pas de quoi décourager billy il poursuit
sa quête
il vient d'apercevoir nico rosberg en
polo gris alors en tête du championnat
du monde de f1 succès avec nico rosberg
qui finit par s'approcher et qu ici
faire à cannes à un câlin merci nico
[Musique]
billy veut alors partager sa joie avec
tout monaco
c'est sa victoire à lui
il est 18 heures dans la cour d'honneur
du palais tout est prêt pour le fameux
cocktail du couple princier le plus
couru du grand prix un décor somptueux
et le privilège rare de pénétrer entre
ses murs
le colonel solaire est sur le pont
bonjour chef
tout est prêt
non pas de plus est magnifique les dieux
sont avec
l'ancien militaire se prépare à
accueillir les invités à l'extérieur ils
sont déjà plusieurs centaines de
privilégiés à patienter avant d'être
reçu par le prince albert ii et la
princesse charlène
pour le colonel solaire un objectif
faire respecter le protocole on va
s'arrêter la tulipe ont reculé d'un tout
petit peu s'il vous plaît pour patienter
tranquillement
[Musique]
personne ne doit entrer avant l'arrivée
du couple princier les invités sont des
décideurs du monde entier des
personnalités internationales des
monégasques ou des amis de la famille
princière
un cocktail amical mais aussi une
opération de relations publiques
c'est grâce à ce genre de réception que
monaco entretient ses amitiés et sa
légende
pendant ce temps le colonel solaire use
de toute sa diplomatie pour faire
patienter les invités et même en
plusieurs langues
c'est toujours un plaisir de vous revoir
on est un peu pas six ans je pense six
ans parce que 800 habitations pour
l'instant à 200 kits sont pas encore
arrivés oui et dire un petit mot gentil
à chacun d'eux et ils valent se
rappelait souvent du moment où il les a
rencontrés et leur dire un petit mot
gentil qui sera adaptée à chaque
personne un chef d'état aux rapports
simples même si son statut peut parfois
impressionnés ses interlocuteurs
c'est à moi de les mettre à l'aise et de
choses se passent bien
allemands et et
le plus naturellement possible départ je
connais depuis très longtemps et puis
d'autres voilà sont des amis qui
viennent de loin
il ya toujours chose à dire quand il ya
des retrouvailles ou d
nouvelle rencontre comme ça souvent est
incroyable il a une mémoire terrible et
il se rappelle le tout est donc cesser
les gens sont très touchées à chaque
fois parce que parce qu'il a ce petit
mot gentil pour chacun d'eux
un protocole que la princesse ancien
sportif de haut niveau connaît désormais
sur le bout des doigts
comment allez-vous ravi de vous revoir
[Musique]
bonjour je suis enchanté de vous
reconnaitre
son rôle de maîtresse de maison très au
sérieux et et les drapeaux à participer
à ce genre de soirées de la meilleure
façon possible dès maintenant
a aussi deux sportifs
c'est un athlète et donc c'est aussi un
grand plaisir pour battre seb
m
deux stars de la f1 sebastien vettel
quadruple champion du monde et kimi
räikkönen
comment allez vous je vous remercie
d'être venus
jamais très loin du prince christine ce
prix là son assistante
ce soir elle est là en tant qu'invité
enfin presque
dépêchez vous il ya beaucoup de monde
j'ai beaucoup travaillé ce soir c'est le
relationnel
ce soir il y a aussi des membres de la
famille princière la princesse caroline
soeur aînée du souverain
comment vas tu
tu es ravissante en robe bleue estivale
c'est la princesse alexandra de hanovre
la fille de la princesse caroline
ambiance chic décontracté et dans ce
cadre féérique magique garantie celle en
or devrait pas vraiment c
c'est vraiment spécial puisqu'il n' rêve
pour beaucoup de monde même pour moi que
chaque fois je viens ici c'est gros
c'est comme une vague
vraiment
un d'eux des sourires
[Musique]
pour albert 2 mission accomplie et tout
comme le grand prix cette soirée au
palais le renvoie à ses souvenirs
d'enfance c'est un grand plaisir vous
savez que les parents avaient instauré
cette réception
la veille du grand prix
qui ne se faisait pas dans la co qui se
faisait
pénalité dans les grands appartements
la première fois que vous avez assisté à
cette soirée au palais
tout neuf ans se faufiler entre les
entre les grandes personnes
vous pensez déjà la manière dont vous
allez préparer vos enfants à ce genre
d'obligation
oui bien sûr mais aussi fort
les habitue rc
cette eau a
voire du monde
à
être milieu de l'adulte dans
je crois que c'est
c'est ça s'en va sans les effrayer il
faut les a examinées petit à petit ce
genre de situation
en cette fin de soirée atmosphère
feutrée au palais princier
en revanche au pied du rocher et ibiza
autour du port sur la piste même du
circuit lesquels ont pris des allures de
boîte de nuit
même sur les yachts orchestre et piste
de danse
mais ici les soirées sont privées
uniquement sur invitation
de quoi amuser les plus fortunés comme
monica bacardi
images uniques et insolites une fois
dans l'année fiesta à ciel ouvert ou
quatre coins du port
pendant le grand prix
cela fait partie du folklore gradins
pleins à craquer
est arrivé du couple princier pour
marquer le top départ de ce grand prix
qui dans cet écrin si particulier
s'affiche comme le plus prestigieux le
plus difficile à gagner au monde
[Musique]
cette année c'est lewis hamilton qui
remporte le trophée
la grande saison d'été est maintenant
lancée et réserve bien d'autres
surprises
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
début juillet monaco devient un pôle
d'attraction pour les touristes de toute
la planète
[Musique]
des touristes prêts à traverser le globe
pour passer leurs vacances dans le plus
petit pays après le vatican
monaco c'est la plus grande
concentration de richesse au monde ici
un habitant sur trois est millionnaire
en été cette machine à rêves avec ses
cinq casinos c8 palace et ses nombreux
événements attirent jusqu'à 2 millions
de visiteurs
ce matin dans le port hercule
un bateau est au centre de toutes les
attentions
ce monstre de 224 m une curiosité
mondial car ce gigantesque paquebot de
croisière le seventies explorer est
considéré comme le plus luxueux
le plus somptueux de la planète
ce soir il va être baptisé en grande
pompe et par une marraine exceptionnel
la princesse charlene un géant plus
aucun immeuble
deux étages de luxe un lancement en
fanfare
alors steph le responsable de
l'hôtellerie du bateau se prépare depuis
des mois à l'événement une grosse
journée quand même aujourd'hui pour
trois journées beaucoup à ce soir la
princesse c'est vraiment un grand moment
beaucoup de fierté beaucoup de stress un
petit peu stress des entendu mais bon on
a une très bonne équipe on est conscient
de ce qu'on fait autre souci puisque ya
beaucoup d'attentes derrière même si
c'était fait stresser
ce navire ultra luxe possède des
arguments qui ont de quoi convaincre une
clientèle très aisée
avec cet escalier monumental digne d'un
décor hollywoodien des lustres en
cristal un palais des merveilles pour
ses 750 passagers avec ses six
restaurants gastronomiques
et son gigantesque espace
avec les toutes dernières tendances
comme cette chambre refroidissante à
zéro degré ça c'est notre cours de notre
chambre
frêche avec les murs en glace et les
sièges qui sont réchauffées mais c'est
quoi ça sert à quoi ça revitaliser après
un massage ou après le sauna justement
pour donner aux encore un petit bout ce
et au dernier étage de ce bateau un
joyau la plus grande suite 350 mètres
carrés contre 50 en général une taille
hors norme pour une cabine
avec sur les murs d'authentiqués oeuvres
d'art comme cette lithographie signé du
maître picasso ou cette collection de
vase lalique
le prix de l' arrêt jane suite 4500
euros par jour et par personne
mais tout compris après votre entrée
nous avons le bas dans la suite dans les
étoiles bas et même de quoi animer les
soirées enchanté et après nous
continuons nous avons bien sûr un balcon
qui fait d'un côté à l'autre du bateau
et nous sommes juste au dessus du pont
du capitaine le majordome est disponible
24 heures sur 24
même si elle a besoin de deux ou trois
tous les moteurs sont à disposition
cette suite dans quatre semaines
dans cette suite trois chambres et dans
la plus grande
l'un des lits les plus chères du monde
cent trente mille euros
[Musique]
le matelas le topper le duvet tout ça
coûte environ avaient du coup ça la mise
en place aux alentours de 150 mille
dollars
nous avons un duvet avec des plumes de
canard qui viennent d'islande ce sont
vraiment des des produits fins rare et
qui ont été faits dans différents
endroits de l'europe et même pour les
oreillers le client a l'embarras du
choix en nous en plumes en orange elle
en tout ce qui est disponible nous avons
un choix d'une dizaine de coussins
disponibles
ils vont très bien dormir très très bien
dormir
20 heures c'est le début de la soirée
d'inauguration 600 invités pour la
plupart des clients qui dès ce soir
partiront de monaco jusqu'à venise à
bord du plus luxueux navire de croisière
du monde
steph s'est mis sur son 31
comme les 540 membres d'équipage
mais le moment que tous attendent
l'arrivée du couple princier
où je vous demande à tous de vous lever
s'il vous plaît
leur altesse sérénissime le prince
albert ii et la princesse charlène de
monaco et la princesse charlene
c'est elle qui va le baptiser ses traces
charlene de monaco merci de me rejoindre
sur la scène pour le lancement de ces
bonnes 6 explorer je bénis le bateau
seventies explorer que dieu le protège
avec tous ces marins
[Musique]
une image qui dès demain grâce au
prestige de la principauté s'affichera
dans les magazines du monde entier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes mi novembre le soleil est à
peine levé
mais déjà dans la cour d'honneur du
palais princier répétition en grande
pompe aujourd'hui 19 novembre sans doute
le jour le plus cher au coeur des
monégasques père fête nationale le jour
où monaco célèbre son prince souverain
le colonel solaire et le colonel
fringant commandant supérieur de la
force publique répète le défilé
militaire
il est prévu dans quelques heures devant
la famille princière et des milliers de
monégasques ordonnance souveraine bla
bla bla bla distribution des médailles
pour la fête du prince évidemment on a
envie de montrer au prince qu'on est les
plus beaux stands et les meilleurs mais
chaque fois qu'on fait quelque chose on
essaie de le faire le mieux possible
donc on on le répète comme dans tous les
corps de métier mais son coeur ah oui je
peux vous dire qu'ils sont au caire est
teintée du tout - et très émue et tout
le monde est monde et l'a complètement
alors en pleine possession de ses moyens
prêts à pour vous que pour donner le
meilleur effet ça c'est certain
[Musique]
on serait bien
pendant que la répétition se poursuit à
l'extérieur au palais pour le colonel
solaire dernière inspection dans l'un
des plus beaux salons à l'endroit même
où dans quelques heures la famille
princière va saluer son peuple voilà
voilà donc dans la salle des glaces un
très bel endroit qui s'inspire un peu là
la grille et glaces de versailles
voulait reconnu avec un magnifique
portrait de la princesse grâce ici c'est
donc là que le prince et la princesse et
leurs familles seront se présenteront au
balcon de ce balcon là demain pour
saluer la prise d'armé pour saluer la
foule
c'est un moment fort et un univers de
légende
chargé d'histoire
comme la célèbre salle du trône
la plus emblématique du pouvoir des
grimaldi depuis 700 ans
c'est sous cette fresque du xvième
siècle et sous les regards de ses aïeux
charles iii et louis 2 que le prince
albert ii a été intronisé le 17 novembre
thomas fouilleron l'historien du palais
c'est l'un des rares à avoir le
privilège de pénétrer librement ici dans
cette pièce surprenante la bibliothèque
privée des grimaldi pour lui un voyage
dans le temps
les livres préférés des souverain de
monaco sont conservés ici depuis 600 ans
et 1 an à un an et demi
le petit prince héréditaire jacques ya
déjà le sien alors nous avons ici un
ouvrage qui a été offert au prince
héréditaire jacques qui est un ouvrage
qui a appartenu à son lointain ancêtre
jacques premier le prince héréditaire
jacques sera un jour jacques deux
princes de monaco
cette édition des essais de montaigne
qui date de 10 733 attendra encore
sagement ici avant d'être lus par le
futur prince régnant je crois que ça
serait dangereux actuellement de les lui
laisser sous là bas il y à ici un bien
très précieux de l'histoire des grimaldi
un trésor familial pour le touché
l'historien met des gants nous avons là
un album privé de photographies de
l'enfance du prince albert ii nous voici
plongés dans l'intimité d'une famille
légendaire toutes les les événements de
toute famille qui rythment l'année de
noël aux anniversaires se sont passées
ici
le prince rainier la princesse grace ont
réussi à transformer aussi en un cocon
familial
ce ce lieu qui pourrait passer pour
austère à balai qui a qu'il ya 700 ans
de d'existence le prince rainier à ces
facétieux et les joueurs avec ses
enfants
une ambiance familiale bien sûr mais pas
tout à fait comme les autres
car depuis leur plus jeune âge le prince
albert et ses soeurs ont participé avec
leurs parents aux obligations
officielles
je pense que c'est pas avant l'âge de 5
6 7 ans que l'on se rencontre vraiment
qu'il ya quelque chose de particulier qu
on n'est pas dans une famille tout à
fait comme les autres et qu'on a
voilà qu'on a quelques responsabilités
et quelques devoirs
la première fois où j'ai dû faire un une
cérémonie officielle père m'avait laissé
je ne dirais pas agir seul mais mais où
je devais faire quelque chose tout seul
si c'est là où j'ai vraiment bien
compris que c'était attendait certaines
choses de moi même même à cet âge là le
destin d'une famille régnante
il en sera de même pour les enfants du
couple princier évidemment ce n'est pas
leur choix mais ils ont le choix de leur
passion et ce sera à eux de choisir dans
quelle voie il seront éduqués
du moment qu'ils savent qu'ils ont une
responsabilité et un devoir envers leur
nation et leurs familles sains et c'est
ce qu'il devrait transmettre aux
générations futures
[Musique]
de l'autre côté de la cour d'honneur
dans la salle du trône
on s'affaire
les lingères du palais sont les
premières à entrer en scène la famille
princière convient aujourd'hui pour le
grand déjeuner de la fête nationale 80
personnalités et notables de la
principauté repassage en cadence
on sait tous le ton anna mais personne
ne va le voir on pas si c'est oui quand
même mais tout ça soit et pour empêcher
le moindre faux plis l'art basse sur le
plateau de l'amidon donc elle reste bien
bien dur un petit peu dur parce que
c'est la fête du presse voilà
et donc que doit être parfait
un grand jour aussi pour ludovic à 17
ans cet élève du lycée hôtelier de
monaco va participer à la préparation du
repas principe c'est la première fois
que cette monégasque pénètrent dans
l'enceinte du palais c'est très très
beau imaginez pas que c'était comme ça
en fait c'est vraiment faim ça château
comme si ça se passe à tous et c'est
magnifique
pas le temps de s'extasier plus
longtemps cette jeune apprenti à
rendez-vous en cuisine à trois heures du
coup d'envoi
c'est l'effervescence c'est le déjeuner
officiel le plus important de l'année
[Musique]
ludovic a est déjà à pied d'oeuvre
c'est vraiment une belle expérience
certes c'est bizarre mais bon c'est
simple et c'est notre prince et ces voix
là c'est moi j'ai grandi ici depuis que
je suis ici donc c'est un plaisir
c
oui c'est bon on a quand même la
pression s comment ça arrive pas tous de
pouvoir servir le prince quand même le
privilège aussi de découvrir les
produits d'exception servi à la table
princière question garcia et le chef du
palais depuis trente ans je vous
présente mario et qui est le président
des producteurs de truffes blanches
d'alba
donc là il nous ramène un diamant de la
région appuient la santé une truffe
blanche qui vient d'italie un produit
très rare donc c'est la truffe blanche
d'alba qui sera rappelée sur les sur la
polenta crémeuse 2
du repas de la fête nationale c'est
super c'est sur les épaules de christian
garcia que repose la réussite de ce
repas principe il faudra bien les
nettoyer
nous sommes habitués à avoir beaucoup de
repas officiels avec des chefs d'état
des princes des présidents mais pour
nous c'est le repas de le repas le plus
important de l'année et le menu est
validée par le prince jusque dans les
moindres détails
le prince albert m'a mis une petite
annotation avec eux pour me demander si
les topinambours seront des challenger
des stamp end et volga 2 ou des fuseaux
je ne vous cache pas que je ne
connaissais pas ces quatre variétés
finalement vous serviront les volga de
dans la salle du trône grand spectacle
pour l'occasion les arts de la table
sont à leur summum verres couverts et
argenterie aux armes de la famille
princière
pour les maîtres d'hôtel précision et
minutie sont de rigueur
on fait attention à ce que les couverts
soit vraiment me donne à bonne distance
les verts à bonne distance et que
lorsque les invités arrivent donc en
début de table que tout soit aligné et
avec des gants en coton pour ne laisser
aucune trace de doigt
mais attention déjà aussi de mettre en
doute les verts accueillent le
monogramme dans le bon sens c'est une
couronne une couronne sur les verts
[Musique]
le prince se positionnera ici dans le
centre de la table et toute la famille
princière est certaine ces invités
seront aussi dans la table centrale dans
moins de deux heures
les 80 invités auront le privilège de
s'asseoir aux côtés de la famille
princière
ludovic à l'élève du lycée hôtelier
découvre l'intérieur du palais avant le
coup de feu
elle accompagne le chef christian garcia
pour une dernière coordination des
équipes
bonjour tout le monde avant chaque
réception officielle
il y à un rituel à l'apéritif vous aurez
des petits macarons foie gras des
macarons au saumon fumé le chef déroule
le détail du menu pour les maîtres
d'hôtel ils pourront informer les
invités si nécessaire le fromage il y
aura le le brie de meaux à la truffe
blanche d'alba y aura du pélardon
fermiers c'est un fromage de chèvre qui
viendra de lozère ce qui est du dessert
dans un tel décor sommes difficiles pour
ludovic à de se concentrer ou la hausse
est magnifique
là tous les dessins qui a c'est vraiment
chiant 300 soit que ces anciens et cette
magnifique se trouvent les lampadaires
fins et c'est parfait c'est super beau
retrouver montano
dans la cour d'honneur la cérémonie
militaire commence c'est ce qu'on
appelle la prise d'armes
le colonel solaire a revêtu sa tenue
d'officier
avant comment la famille princière
presque au complet
moment solennel
le prince albert ii et la princesse
charlène
la princesse caroline avec ses enfants
charlotte casiraghi pierre casiraghi et
son épouse béatrice borromeo et aux
côtés de la princesse stéphanie la
princesse alexandra fille de caroline
monaco a une capacité militaire limitée
3 100 carabiniers sapeurs pompiers
assurent la défense du prince et du
palais mais en cas d'agression c'est la
france qui assure la protection de
monaco
[Musique]
à l'extérieur sur la place du palais des
milliers de spectateurs pour l'événement
le plus symbolique de l'année
chaque automne le 19 novembre les
monégasques revêtent le rouge et le
blanc les couleurs de la principauté
depuis 1857
la coutume veut que le souverain et sa
famille apparaissent aux fenêtres
c'est très important aux riches que
d'habitude puis on affirme notre tâche
moment où notre souverain
sa famille était des fois bien sûr où
l'on va voir avec des enfants j'imagine
d'ambiance et toutes les manifestations
mariage derrière les fenêtres de la
salle des glaces
le prince albert ii se prépare à ce
rendez vous avec ces sujets un moment
rare pour la première fois les jumeaux
le prince jacques et la princesse
gabriela vont vivre aujourd'hui dans les
bras de leurs parents leur première fête
nationale le moment que tous attendent
apparition du couple princier au balcon
[Musique]
et à la tène être voisine la famille
grimaldi
les monégasques sont comblés
[Applaudissements]
dans la salle du trône les notables de
la principauté prennent place pour le
déjeuner officiel
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande de
vous lever
le protocole veut que la famille
princière arrive après ses invités
s'élance mesdames messieurs le monde
accueillant leurs altesses
la famille et naître dans la pièce par
ordre de placement à table le repas peut
commencer
au total 22 serveurs pour ce déjeuner le
plus prestigieux de l'année
si dans la salle du trône tout le monde
se détend un étage en dessous
autre ambiance
[Musique]
on évalue à l'accès est en cuisine
la brigade du chef christian garcia est
sous tension allez on rappela plus
souvent pour l'import allez on en voit
paul npa la truffe blanche et sauté
d'agneau aux asperges du challenge
chacun des 80 convives doit être servi
en même temps la table princière
d'apprécier allez on y va
le déjeuner va durer une heure quinze et
à la fin du repas dans les cuisines
verdict le prince m'a chargé de tous
vous remercier en son nom il était
vraiment très très content de du repas
bravo à tous et merci encore cette année
encore les 250 employés du palais et les
monégasques se seront mobilisés pour
offrir au prince la plus belle défaite
fin décembre changement de décor dans la
principauté sur la place du casino les
palmiers ont laissé la vedette aux
sapins
et les monégasques ont le regard tourné
vers le palais car ici albert ii et
charlène de monaco s'apprête à passer un
noël pas comme les autres
leur premier noël de parents avec
jacques et gabriela leurs jumeaux
la découverte de nouvelles émotions
mélange de souvenirs de bonheur partagé
et d'émerveillement sont déjà très je
crois très joueur très bouger en
permanence surtout jacques sont très
actifs et très curieux de tout et c'est
ça qui est merveilleux
cet âge là c'est que l a découverte
permanente de beaucoup de choses
un ballet transformée en gigantesque
maison du père noël
car à monaco cette fête se célèbrent
aussi avec la grande famille des
monégasques
le colonel solaire le chambellan se
prépare à une mission exceptionnelle
cet après midi 600 petits monégasques
seront accueillis ici pour un noël au
palais avec le couple princier les
enfants arriveront par là et sont
accompagnés par ce passage
ce matin la salle du trône est devenue
une salle de spectacle pour enfants
le 3 ne ressens plus la salle du trône
ne ressens plus la salle du trône là on
a prévu 2 tab
il faut mettre deux hommes et quatre
chaises longues années l'ancien
monégasque embêté c'est parce qu'ils le
valent bien
à part comme ça
[Musique]
un spectacle de danse mais surtout le
prince et la princesse vont offrir
personnellement à chacun des enfants
un cadeau de noël le petit salon
d'apparat c'est lui aussi métamorphosé
en magasin de jouets on est chez le père
noël s'est il a pris ses quartiers ici
pendant pendant cette journée
on le verra tout à l'heure s'ils sont
jouées classés en fonction de l'âge
chaque monégasque de 6 à 12 ans recevra
un cadeau des mains du souverain dont le
prince est très impliqué ouvert cet
après midi il est très impliqué par
cette remise aux cadeaux il adore ça
vraiment 31 une erreur de cadeaux ils
adorent reprendre les choses en main il
rappelle au père noël quel est son
travail
noël au palais une tradition vieille de
65 ans instaurée par la princesse grâce
la mère du prince
[Musique]
en ce début d'après midi les familles
monégasque convergent vers le rocher
katherine et ses deux enfants marine et
pierre sont très attachés à cette
tradition pour les monégasques souviens
d'être allé au palais quand il était
enfant et avoir participé au spectacle
ça participe à cimenter à construire
aussi ce sentiment de d'appartenance la
communauté monégasque qui à l'as mandé
il ya les copains qui attendent c'est
sympa aussi voilà deux ils se retrouvent
tous les ans parle plusieurs jours avant
donc il ya lentilles la joie de
l'anticipation et l'ajout du moment pour
ses enfants
c'est l'euphorie un enthousiasme partagé
par leurs parents qui revivent
aujourd'hui leurs souvenirs d'enfance
ces moments magiques et donc moi je les
fais quand j'étais petit jusqu'à 12 ans
ainsi caroline stéphanie
à terme on pourra famille
et chaque petit monégasque a reçu son
invitation nominative utilisé à la boue
de noël offert aux grands centres oil &
gas
les parents ne sont pas conviés alors
ultimes recommandations avec qui vous
êtes sages comme d'habitude assure exit
pas comme des fous et on n'oublie pas de
dire quoi au prince où la princesse qui
est bien sinon tu peux le dire merci
tout court elle sera content
non mon seigneur pour le prince et on
peut dire merci madame à la fin c'est
logique et c'est parti pour le voyage
enchanté
[Musique]
le croate bat le crabe
les petits lutins sont
et comme d'habitude le colonel s'adapte
[Musique]
jamais
en france principal j'aurais choisi que
des adultes à suhr ça change
complètement le sens moins disciplinés
mais bon tir de gobbi gentil
et finalement le prince et la princesse
en personne
[Applaudissements]
allez on suit ensuite reçus
allez les enfants on y va on dit apple
corps
tata plus haut quoi c'est à côté du
prince
et la princesse et les abus oui bon coup
de vent violent
malgré ce pépin de francs si la chérie
d'albert peu français alors on nie pas
la chérie d'albert andy la princesse ah
oui il faut dire la princesse et par le
français oui oui oui
monseigneur voilà mon seigneur lui dit
monseigneur et la princesse on lui dit
madame prend l'eau ou alors on lui dit
altesse
là
voilà le protocole arrière pour un saké
coule c'est terriblement bon tellement
amusant c'est tellement sympa et dans ce
décor toujours le même effet des étoiles
plein les yeux
[Applaudissements]
cet après midi le couple princier est
totale
[Applaudissements]
le spectacle peut commencer
une demi heure plus tard la distribution
des cadeaux aussi sans s'avancer je
m'avance et j'ai journée où ça en est là
haut je fais déjà dérouleront place et
tu veux tu commences à faire démarrer
parce que là ils vont être prêts pour le
petit pierre et ses amis dernière
révision du protocole si la fille
[Musique]
une attention particulière et des
cadeaux nominatifs pour chacun
[Musique]
à la droite du couple princier les
enfants de la princesse stéphanie louis
ducruet et camille gottlieb
j'avais un à temps
si je peux trouver leurs données mais sa
démarche
vous aimez bien jouer l'alternance c'est
pas que j'ai joué les père - jl mettez
le final le coureur il est l'âme je vais
pas prendre sa place c'est la jungle à
un dilemme pour finir c'est très
important parce que lamentable
voilà ça crée un lien alors gacia
chutait
deux heures de distribution et des
images plein la tête
[Musique]
à chacun son jouet pour pierre et ses
amis
non moi c'est rageant
j'ai refusé mec
jours
m
de truquer lesquels on s'amuserait bien
avant tout sur les hélicoptères des
matches comme ça il s'en fait compris on
peut s'amuser
c'était la fête des enfants mais à
l'extérieur du palais les plus émues ce
sont peut-être les mamans
je souhaite aussi
quand on est enfant on est impressionné
de voir le classer la princesse
ah oui ça vous aimez vraiment
[Musique]
au delà du glamour une émotion simple un
lien sincère avec le couple princier et
pour la dynastie des grimaldi
chaque grand rendez-vous de famille gais
ou tristes se vit aussi avec les
monégasques en cette fin janvier
ce soir une curiosité dans le port de
monaco
[Applaudissements]
jacques pour chaque scène top départ de
la barre entre lio télé hors bord ce
petit voilier il ne paye pas de mine
pourtant tous l'attendent toujours
elle même en démo sur préparer la
colombe pour la colombe ce soir presque
une cérémonie d'un autre âge mais est ce
que c'est arrêtez vous c'est bien on va
s'arrêter comme ça c'est bien
un milliers de monégasques célèbre la
plus lointaine tradition religieuse de
leur histoire une fois par an il célèbre
la sainte patronne de monaco sainte
dévote
[Musique]
la légende au 4e siècle cette jeune
femme corse et martyrisé à mort par les
romains puis son corps est déposé dans
une barque qui s'échouent au pied du
rocher
guidés par une colombe même si d'autres
cultes ont leur place à monaco c'est le
catholicisme qui est reconnu comme
religion d'état mais père s'il vous
plaît ici centre est ici non moi
l'organisateur n'a que quelques minutes
pour mettre de l'ordre dans les rangs et
ce n'est pas facile
bonjour on se met la voix ce matin on va
se battre parce que les bateaux gens
polis ils sont à vue toute façon il le
sait jacques les pénitente ce sont ces
femmes en noir et blanc qui oeuvrent
bénévolement pour l'église c'est
monégasque ne rateraient pour rien au
monde cette cérémonie qui perdure sur le
rocher depuis dix-sept siècles
c'est le privilège des anciens et la
transmission pour l'est pour les plus
jeunes il faut perpétuer la tradition
ok on peut y aller doucement
[Musique]
la procession peut démarrer autour des
reliques de sainte dévote
[Musique]
contraste saisissant entre tradition et
modernisme
pour quelques heures dévotion et
recueillement
[Musique]
quoique
monaco rhône où ce soir avec ses
origines
chargé
la procession arrive devant la petite
église de sainte dévote tout près du
port
les reliques ont dit être exposée
[Musique]
depuis 300 ans les princes de monaco
président cette cérémonie ancestrale les
mêmes gestes les mêmes postures de
génération en génération
[Musique]
les deux manches devant leurs princes
les pénitents tu y met du coeur
où
[Musique]
oh
pendant que le couple princier se
recueille devant les reliques
à l'extérieur on prépare un cérémonial
l'embrasement d'une barque
[Musique]
monseigneur vous en faites vous en prie
c'est au prince et à la princesse
d'officiers moment le plus symbolique et
spectaculaire de cette fête
la légende de ce pays raconte qu'au
moyen âge des malfaiteurs auraient volé
les reliques de sainte dévote
en représailles leur barque fut brûlé
les reliques récupérer pense que les les
traditions c'est ce qui nous permet de
nous de comprendre les choses et savoir
d'où on vient on dit pour savoir où on
va vous dire savoir d'où on vient donc
je pense poids un roc solide et s'il y
en a et puis à partir de là on peut
construire
retour au palais du couple princier bon
je vous laisse parce que là il faut que
j'y aille
comme souvent à monaco une fin de soirée
en apothéose
[Applaudissements]
ce matin monaco se prépare à vibrer avec
la soirée la plus courue de tout le
rocher ce soir au sporting club
le légendaire bal de la rose qui marque
le début du printemps dans la
prestigieuse salle des étoiles
installation d'un décor digne de
hollywood
c'est la princesse caroline de hanovre
en personne qu'il organise et à la vue
grand pour ce gala de charité au profit
des enfants défavorisés 900 riches
donateurs sont conviés ici autour de la
famille princière
bonjour est ce que vous savez si
monsieur ringot et là
[Musique]
mécha richard hannon restant étendu
c'est pourtant une star de
l'organisation des événements de
prestige depuis 25 ans la princesse
caroline fait appel à cette parisienne
pour rendre cet événement inoubliable
et chaque année c'est un challenge
la princesse hier soir on est resté
jusqu'à 00h30 à pour les répétitions et
elle a refait le plan donc voilà
maintenant il faut que toute la brigade
s'adapte pour que la table soit de la
bonne taille et que les trains soient
bien en face de l'autre on prend des 101
un oeil sur tout car elle n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur
enfin c'est pas droit par exemple voyez
cette table à epa droite elle est un peu
l'air en arc de cercle
c'est ça le souci du détail même si
personne ne le voie moi je le vois donc
on a quand même la responsabilité de
cette soirée
il faut que tout soit parfait je me sens
pour l'instant encore calme et ça va pas
durer
sur scène surprise l'animateur stéphane
bern est en pleine répétition
c'est dieu madame alice nous allons donc
maintenant au tirage de la tombola
c'est la princesse caroline qui l'a
choisi objectif animer cet événement et
surtout la tombola
l'un des points d'orgue de la soirée il
faut qu'ils se mettent il s'écarte un
peu et toi tu sois milieu
vingt ans que stéphane bern participent
mais elle reste vigilante
voilà je pense que c'est mieux et d
approcher un peu parce que tel qui soit
si loin oui il ya plusieurs plaisante
mais il a le trac est toujours un
pincement au coeur parce que vous dites
vous allez parler devant 900 personnes
je m'adresse quand même au prince
souverain à la princesse souveraine et
puis à la princesse caroline léger connu
des années où les enfants c'est à dire
des enfants de la princesse caroline me
faisais des petits coups en 12 me
faisais des vannes parce que c'est ça
reste une ambiance extrêmement
chaleureuse et sympathique
ce que j'aime c'est à toutes les saisons
il se passe quelque chose
ambiance cubaine le thème choisi cette
année par la princesse caroline pour la
conception du décor elle a fait appel à
un ami intime
karl lagerfeld le célébrissime couturier
chaque année depuis cinq ans son défi
faire rêver les 900 convives avec ses
décors immeuble de la havane nappe rond
de serviette jusqu'au carton
d'invitation tout est dessiné par le m à
l'intérieur vous avez les dessins que
carla fait il à donner les impulsions il
a donné les idées ont même entraîné des
saints les a corrigés et les à modifier
et
il dit elle avoue m'avait déçu ça c'est
des catastrophes on n'espère pas mais
pas tranquille
karl lagarfeld doit arriver dans deux
heures je vais voir si la salle a changé
dans l'entrée du sporting l'un des défis
de la soirée reconstituer les paysages
de la havane encore en vrac canne à
sucre fleurs exotiques banane un vrai
casse-tête rendre ce décor esthétique et
pratique ici ce soir on attend une
cinquantaine de photographes pour les
magazines du monde entier pour faire
attention que ça déborde pas trop de
c'est pas quelle est la limite parce que
tu voyais les photographes qui sont en
face et il faut pas qu'ils aient des
cannes à sucre qui j'aime charlotte
risque d'avoir ou ou pierre la canne à
sucre sur le visage et ce sera pas de
bol des bonus
[Musique]
et
pour ce décor presque un exploit des
milliers de fleurs et de fruits
exotiques ont été importés directement
de cuba par avion juste pour un soir
[Musique]
c'est des fleurs vraiment du pays de
cuba
côté cuisine même farandole exotique
mais cette fois côté saveurs pour le
dessert une vraie curiosité
ce soir l'un des emblèmes de cuba le
cigare sera en sucre grandeur nature
dans une composition originale
je suis parti sur sur un cigare avec une
mousse chocolat bio de république
dominicaine avec un rom rome cubaine 15
ans d'âge
un petit comme crumble chocolat pour
appeler un peu les cendres du cigare et
des petites allumettes
les tigres et c'est un animateur dans
l'entrée du sporting 1 à la boule au
ventre
dans quelques instants karl lagerfeld
sera là pour valider le décor qu'il a
imaginé resterai sans lier oui c'est
stressant c'est très strict
là on attend de calme et lui il n'a vu
que des dessins donc maintenant il va
voir la réalisation on espère ne pas les
décevoir mairie qui peut emmener
toujours mais tend vers l'est mais tu
les rentrer mais les dents de cette
salle des mois qu'elle travaille sur ce
bal alors quel sera le verdict de celui
que certains appellent le kaiser c'est à
dire l'empereur
[Musique]
au même moment dans le ciel de la côte
d'azur à bord de cet hélicoptère dit à
l'ats maquis à dubaï c'est une vedette
de la télé elle a fait 4000 kilomètres
pour assister ce soir au célèbre bal de
la rose
[Musique]
j'adore venir à monaco en hélico la vue
est incroyable je suis très excité
d'être là même si je reste peu de temps
mais deux jours à monaco c'est top
que puis je demandais plus
on est enfin arrivé
personne n'est mort j'ai toujours le
sort et pour l'occasion c'est monaco qui
invite car la présence ici de cette
jeune femme très suivie sur les réseaux
sociaux au moyen-orient est une
publicité garantie pour la principauté
quant à elle elle compte bien profiter
de la notoriété du bal de la rose et des
personnalités présentes pour rencontrer
des gens influents et grâce à cela
tenter de devenir célèbre en europe
le bal de la rose c'est une soirée que
je ne veux pas manquer j'ai vraiment
envie de rencontrer le prince albert je
vais rater à dubaï où il était en
mission il ya quelques semaines au spac
je pense que ce bal c'est le bon endroit
pour élargir son réseau
il y a des gens entreprenants et c'est
ça le côté sympa de mon job du business
certes mais tous les rêves sont permis
peut-être que je vais être comme
cendrillon
quand je vais quitter le bas je vais me
transformer et je vais rencontrer
l'homme de ma vie
c'est ce que vous cherchez non pas pour
le moment mais si je le rends compte
pourquoi pas une invitée de marque que
la principauté a logé dans l'un de ses
plus beaux palaces l'ermitage tout
proche de la place du casino
traitement presque princier on lui a
même réservé une surprise aux leçons de
tu veux
[Musique]
galerie oeuvre d'art est derrière cette
porte
bienvenue dans votre chambre une suite
un appartement de 100 m² chambre à
coucher salle à manger salon tout
higuain
avec en prime
[Musique]
c'est le pain a dit une vue incroyable
ah ouais moi j'aimerais me levais tous
les matins en voyant ça regardez ça il
n'y a rien de plus beau et sur sa
terrasse
elle pourra même profiter de la vue
depuis son jacuzzi
[Musique]
ma place préférée dans les hôtels c'est
la salle de bains elle doit être top
il m'a suite est immense mais la salle
de bains est tout petit
c'est bizarre à quelques heures du bal
son rituel avant une grande soirée un
petit tour au spar et ça se passe cinq
étages plus bas
au bout de ce couloir un paradis pour
femmes fortunées ma masseuse et les
meilleurs vins du monde
je pourrais m'en dormir là je suis
tellement jet lag et c'est une
obligation avant un événement comme
celui-ci
j'ai entendu qu'il y aura 900 personnes
ce soir il devant l'entrée du sporting
autre ambiance
anne l'organisatrice fait les cent pas
l'arrivée de karl lagerfeld est
imminente
le grand couturier va découvrir et juger
son travail
[Musique]
lunettes noires catogan et gants de cuir
lemaitre fait son entrée le pape de la
mode est réputé pour son ultra exigence
et son génie de l'élégance année dans
ses petits souliers
quelques coups d'oeil le créateur s'est
fait une idée et le verdict tombe
[Applaudissements]
soulagement pour anne lemaitre est
satisfait du décor reste à ce que la
famille princière et les convives
passent la plus belle des soirées lors
de ce gala de charité à quelques
centaines de mètres du sporting on se
prépare également aux balles dans cette
villa privée l'un des rares hôtels
particuliers de la principauté 800
mètres carrés sur quatre étages ce soir
la propriétaire des lieux
monica bacardi est euphorique cette
résidente monégasque est une habituée
des grands rendez-vous de la principauté
et ce soir dilemme c'est toujours
difficile
aussi j'avais masqué en plus moi je suis
toujours dernière seconde alors je me
pose toujours la question qu'est ce que
je pourrais m et qu'est ce que c'est le
plus adapté uniquement des robes de
haute couture mais difficile de choisir
alors elle appelle à la rescousse son
fidèle majordome achève s'il vous plaît
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous pas que
cette robe avec ses chaussures
magnifique comme ça voilà l'équation
jeudi l'année prochaine je vais perdre 5
à 6 kg mais bien trois sets et et comme
ça je mettrai une robe rose pour la
balle de la roja cette année c'est
encore le noir
côté chaussures pas de doute voilà pour
faire un peu rock n'roll moi j'aime
toujours avait un petit talent sur
rock'n'roll comme ça si quelqu'un n'est
pas gentil avec moi j'ai fais ou alors
je mets la bibitte fait jour
modique à bacardi habite depuis 20 ans
dans cette ville a ici la décoration
oscille entre le grand classique et la
modernité
certaines oeuvres valent jusqu'à 500
mille euros pour la soirée reste
l'accessoire indispensable
les diamants pourtant on est un peu de
luminosité et pour ça elle a l'embarras
du choix
je m'excuse chez elle et vous pourrez
m'aider
j'arrive pas tout seul c'est bon j'ai
cliqué salaires c'est bon oui voila
merci beaucoup
moi je pensais je veux pas mettre des
boucles d'oreilles va faire tout de
suite trop précis semblent l'arbre de
noël et sur vos copains que ça laisse un
peu discret et raffiné nos sacs prêt
pour l'action
retour à l'hôtel hermitage je suis super
excité d'y à la main qui s'apprête à
faire sa sortie dans le grand monde
la vedette de télé a choisi une robe de
princesse j'ai besoin dead avec cette
robe accompagné de son assistante
personnelle diala compte bien faire
sensation
son objectif se faire des relations pour
développer sa carrière en europe
robe longue avec trend et corse est pas
toujours facile respirer mais sarah
clichés ultra glamour à destination de
ses admirateurs de son blog et surtout
de ses 180 mille abonnés une blogueuse
de prestige pour des photos d'une soirée
à monaco qui feront le tour du
moyen-orient je me prends en photo pour
mes fans invités cette blogueuse c'est
bénéficié d'une grosse publicité dans
les pays du golfe
un vivier de clients potentiels pour la
principauté
vous restez connectés allez à la place
d'un téléphone au nom à 4 au cas où il
ya un souci 20 heures
top départ de la soirée c'est le ballet
des voitures de luxe et de collection
des robes de bal élégante ou étonnantes
dans ce décor exotique c'est le défilé
du glamour des jolies femmes et des
riches donateurs
jet set noblesse monde des affaires
les invités se pressent des quatre coins
du monde et la magie fonctionne
oui c'est ça
c'est très rare oui parce qu'il ya des
fruits aussi il n'y a pas seulement les
roses cette année
c'est un coup bas rhin plus être et cuba
ambiance cubaine même pour les
photographes
un rituel avant de pénétrer dans la
salle affiché son plus beau sourire pour
la presse internationale
finalement monica bacardi sont ses
boucles d'oreille mais avec un chevalier
servant
stéphane bern suivi de dyala maquis qui
fait sensation
la salle des étoiles brille de tous ses
feux dits à la maquille aussi elle
découvre et s'interroge
voilà je vous en prie pas sur cette
table merci beaucoup
où est la table du prince la table du
prince est au milieu oui donc je suis
proche
la salle affiche complet ce que tous
attendent à présent les voici
le prince albert ii fait son entrée avec
sa soeur aînée la princesse caroline
instauré par sa mère la princesse grâce
caroline de monaco organise ce bal
depuis 33 ans
et cette année pour la première fois ses
quatre enfants sont réunis
[Musique]
pierre casiraghi accompagné de son
épouse béatrice borromeo
m
charlotte casiraghi
[Musique]
andrea et son épouse tatiana santo
domingo et surtout alexandra de hanovre
16 ans la benjamine
c'est son premier bal de la rose
et bien sûr le maïs trop de la haute
couture karl lagerfeld pour une photo
rarissime
et c'est par la scène que la famille
fait son entrée sous les
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
smoking bijoux et jolies femmes les
membres de la famille princière se sont
dispersés à différentes tables pour
honorer leurs invités
de son côté le charme de dia lama qui
opère elle n'a pas de mal à nouer des
contacts et à se faire des relations
sur le registre voir et se faire voir
pari réussi
cet homme est un roi des réseaux sociaux
oui on a parlé de nos métiers de nos
passions et j'ai aussi rencontré un
styliste un designer on a parlé mode
design
donc je vais rentrer à la maison avec de
nouveaux contacts
1 tu viens me voir et dubaï oui bien sûr
c'est ça qui est super dans ce genre de
soirée
on va faire des
musique magie et féerie
cette année encore le bal de la rose
aura tenu toutes ses promesses
le prince albert ii et le quatorzième de
la lignée des grimaldi a régné sur le
rocher depuis 700 ans pour lui et la
princesse au coeur du palais l'enjeu
pérenniser l'héritage de leurs ancêtres
et conservé à monaco cette aura qui
fascine le monde entier
[Musique]